now at a time when public attention is
particularly focused on
medical advances of course coronavirus
this year's nobel prize for medicine has
been awarded
for the discovery of the hepatitis c uh
virus the work of americans harvey alter
and charles rice and britain michael
horton
were honored in stockholm the prize is
especially significant this year as the
world grapples with
the kovit 19 pandemic this year's
nobel prize in physiology or medicine
awards the discovery of the hepatitis c
virus a major cause of liver
inflammation
also known as hepatitis
in their latest report the world health
organization
estimated over 70 million cases of
hepatitis c globally
this is likely an underestimation as
many cases
go undiagnosed
hepatitis c causes 400 000
deaths annually and it's one of the most
common causes
of liver cancer and liver
transplantation
okay let's talk now to dr gilbert
thompson in london he's author of the
book
nobel prizes that changed medicine he's
uh
emeritus professor at imperial college
in
london dr thompson good to have you here
on the newshour
how significant was this discovery
very significant indeed it
revolutionized the
safety of blood transfusions for
thousands of people
in the past uh there was what was called
non-a non-b hepatitis and this seemed to
be associated with
transfused blood particularly blood that
had been obtained obtained from
paid blood donors many of whom i think
were probably drug
addicts and virtually no
infections resulting from volunteer
blood donors
and the work of um of how of
alter and howton as i say has
completely transformed medicine and
arguably
has saved millions of lives probably
quite a bit more than so far the
coronavirus has
uh has done does this mean that if the
team
behind this discovery have discovered
and been able to
tag and identify the virus by definition
i guess we're one step closer
to being able to come up with a vaccine
you mean for the coronavirus no for this
particular condition that we're
discussing
the hepatitis c yes
um
i don't think there is a vaccine for
i i could be wrong but um i think the
main
result of the discovery of
hepatitis c was that it was possible to
check all blood
or contamination with this virus before
it was transfused
um and as far as treatment of people
who've actually
got hepatitis c i think
the the drugs that are now used very
successfully to cure
such individuals resulted from the work
done by charles rice
at the rockefeller where he successfully
cloned um the virus
and was able to undertake studies
in vitro with cultured human cells
liver cells and thereby
help the drug industry to develop
these combinations of drugs which are
curious
okay we'll leave it there dr gilbert
thompson talking to us on skype from
london good to talk to you sir thank you
very much
thank you